now she's best known as the original
influencer as well as being the heiress
to the hilton hotel chain
paris hilton is an accomplished
businesswoman model and
dj now paris hilton is trying to clear
away some of the misconceptions about
herself in her new documentary
this is paris but in her only uk
broadcast interview the star told sky
news
that the film was also an opportunity to
address some dark parts of her past
sadia chowdhury has this report i feel
like
the whole world thinks they know me
a glamorous socialite who's had even the
most intimate details of her life
told over and over again paris hilton
has decided it's time
she tells her story i feel that there's
just been so many misconceptions about
me
so i wanted to show people who i really
was in the film ms hilton will open up
about a sex tape
released by her then boyfriend 16 years
ago
back then they
made me like i was the villain and
i'm so grateful that times have changed
and now
women are getting the respect that they
deserve because
i wasn't you know obviously
lucky in that situation but today at
least there's change
so i'm happy for the future of women
that they wouldn't have to go through
something like that because it's
one of my biggest regrets of my life and
something
that will traumatize me for the rest of
my life
here we are at paris in school she'll
tell stories in her film she says
even her family aren't aware of claims
she was physically abused at school
when i was even in the editing room i
was like
we need to cut this out i don't want
anyone hearing about this
but now that the trailers came out
i'm getting just an outpour of
emails and people contacting me
survivors who have been at the same
school the school
now under different ownership didn't
comment on the allegations
born into wealth as the granddaughter of
the founder of the hilton hotels chain
today she's a businesswoman in her own
right
she's worth an estimated 300 million
dollars
but the woman who describes herself as
the original
influencer admits fame and money hasn't
brought her happiness
sadia chowdhury sky news